the president wants to show the world
that he can work with Senate Republican
leader Mitch McConnell the two men met
reporters in the Rose Garden yesterday
after a White House meeting the
president said that he and McConnell are
quote closer than ever before they
appeared after mr. Trump's former chief
strategist at Steve Manon declared a
season of war against the GOP
establishment major Garrett was in the
Rose Garden yesterday asking all the
questions major good morning good
morning he was just a week ago that a
senior Senate Republican referred to
this White House as an adult day care
center that meant the president and the
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
needed a unity photo-op and they needed
it badly wasn't easy though what was the
president's good friend Steve been and
waiting in the wings with threats of
political retribution against McConnell
and other supposedly wayward Republicans
he's a friend of mine and he's very
committed to getting things passed that
Steve is Steve Bannon the exiled White
House chief strategist president Trump
likes to use against Senate Republicans
it's a season of war against a GOP
establishment the main target sent a
majority leader Mitch McConnell
the donors are not happy they've all
left you we've cut your oxygen off Mitch
okay for the president Bannon is a
threat he can deploy before his cabinet
I know how he feels it depends on who
you talking about there are some
Republicans frankly that should be
ashamed of themselves and then ignore
less than two hours later the Republican
Party is very very unified McConnell
scorned by the president in August I'm
very disappointed in Mitch now a
potential man of the hour we've been
friends for a long time and McConnell
with no other choice played along we
have the same agenda we've been friends
and acquaintances for a long time the
commander in chief was also asked why he
withheld public comment on four US
soldiers killed in an ambush nearly two
weeks ago in Nazaire the president said
letters will soon be sent to the
families he then said this about his
predecessors look at President Obama and
other presidents most of them didn't
make also a lot of them didn't make
calls officials for President Obama
George W Bush and Clinton told CBS all
three made calls to families of the
Fallen mr. Obama's Attorney General
tweeted
the damn lying you're the president
White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders said last night the president
quote wasn't criticizing predecessors
but stating a fact Sanders said previous
presidents have used various methods to
contact families of the Fallen visits
letters and calls and the point she said
the president was trying to make is that
not every predecessor called every
grieving military family Nora all right
major thank you very much